making drawings on land on quite a large
scale is something people can do for
thousands of years
[Music]
i'm simon beck
and i make drawings in the snow
[Music]
it started as a bit of fun
but gradually it's taken over my life
a ballpark estimate of footsteps
about 5000 steps in an hour
a big drawing
two hours measuring eight hours work
you're looking at forty 000 steps
[Music]
i started doing it as an easier
alternative to hiking at the mountain
when i wanted some exercise
you're starting with a drawer on a piece
of paper
or else to draw it in your mind
just treating it being like an
orienteering map you're just going a
certain distance in a certain direction
to determine distances by counting bases
it's a very physical exercise it's
equivalent to a long days walking in the
hills when you make one of these big
drawings
[Music]
i'm just about the only person in the
world doing anything like it
[Music]
[Music]
this incredible colorful city
will only last a few months
but for one local designer the seasonal
spectacular is worth it
[Music]
jin zhang is an award-winning ice
sculptor and art teacher in harbin china
carbine is known as the city of ice and
each year hosts the incredible spectacle
the harbin snow and ice festival
these large-scale designs are remarkable
but it's quite a process
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
be
starting with a block of plain ice may
seem daunting but to jin n this is just
the beginning
[Music]
of
foreign
[Music]
but the reality of working with a
seasonal medium has its downfalls
foreign
[Music]
water is just such an amazing medium
you can just see the crystals and how
they form in so many different ways and
then take that and extrapolate it to
these huge cliffs
what we do here is create spray ice and
probably make over 300 different climbs
[Music]
my name is alexander bianchi and i'm an
ice farmer we're down here in the
uncompacted gorge
we have a water system at the top of the
gorge
these galvanized steel shower heads
and it basically just sprays water out
over the cliffs and overnight when it's
cold it forms ice along the cliffs
what we really want is a nice clean
surface for the new water to come down
and just keep building off of that so a
lot of what we do here actually is repel
down a lot of these faces and just try
to clear that snow off ready for the
next layer
there's about two miles of ice if you
walk the bottom of the canyon and yeah
we farm ice all along the top of it
being an ice farmer is it's kind of hard
work we're going to open up the south
valve
sometimes i think we're no more than
like glorified plumbers
ice farming is art and engineering i
mean the two i think are always really
inseparable you know the engineering is
the logistics how do we get water from
point a to point b sometimes if the
valves aren't cracked quite enough you
get a little bit of a freeze up the
water just doesn't get to the valve the
remedy is a blow torch
on the artistic side is once we have
this water where we need it how can we
do something different how can we make
something interesting that you know
we've never
climbed before it's definitely an
artistic process for some of us
i grew up rock climbing you know fair
weather climber first time i came out
here
was just kind of blown away it's so
different than rock climbing you're
climbing a transient medium the rock is
always going to be there this this ice
is not always there so it creates this
diversity and
this intense experience that i really
don't find in other facets of climate
and that's why i'm proud to do what i'm
doing
[Music]
i was the snowflake consultant on the
movie frozen
they wanted to get all the snowflakes
right and so they asked me you know how
they grow and i was very pleased when
the movie came out they all looked like
real snowflakes none of them were
eight-sided they were all six-sided and
so good job
my name is ken lebrecht and i'm a
professor of physics here at caltech
and i also grow snowflakes
well i got into physics very early i've
been doing that most of my life maybe
about 20 years ago i just got interested
in how crystals grow and that sort of
led me to ice and to snowflakes we still
don't exactly understand why they look
like they do so it's kind of fun to
think about
to make a snowflake in the lab you start
with water and water vapor and you got
to get everything cold and basically
start a crystal growing and i'll kind of
blow moist air down onto it and it just
absorbs water vapor from the air and
starts to grow and i can do this on a
piece of glass and so just watch it grow
i'm the only one that makes snowflakes
like this in the lab
when you start to look really carefully
at how a snowflake works you find you
don't understand it and there's a lot
going on you dig deeper there's more and
more stuff and it's it's really very
interesting to me anyway
i love to go out and sort of hunt for
snowflakes because these beautiful works
of art are just falling all over
and you pick a few of them up and
photograph them and the rest of them you
just trample on at the end of the day
i'm trying to understand how atoms and
molecules fit together to form crystals
and by studying snowflakes slowly you
figure things out that are that are
useful
one snowflake at a time
[Music]
feeling cold is
physically painful
it hurts your
fingers it hurts your feet it hurts your
face
[Music]
it's also
potentially very life threatening
my focus really is anything cold so if
there is ice or snow or a cold breeze i
want to go there
but i've focused mostly on the polar
regions both in the arctic and antarctic
only 48 people have completed the
unsupported unaided expedition in the
north pole compared to mount everest
where 6 000 people have summoned
it's the most difficult expedition on
the planet to a place that few people
understand
a lot of what we see on an expedition to
the arctic ocean is nothing it's like
being on the inside of a ping-pong ball
basically you can't see any sort of
differentiation from the sky to the
horizon to the snow surface
it's also incredible to look out on a
clear day and see the sheets of ice that
are rafted together like blocks as big
as houses pressured in these amazing
incredible shapes you can't help but
just stop and be amazed
this is my third expedition the north
pole the arctic ocean is changing very
quickly compared to a lot of other
places scientists estimate that the
arctic ocean will be ice free in less
than 50 years in the summertime
unfortunately we find ourselves not
doing these adventures because they're
there anymore but because they might not
be there in the future
our north pole trip realistically may be
the last of its kind in history and so
it was very important for me to do this
adventure so that people have an idea of
what this place is like right now
so that we can look back and say this is
what we once had
[Music]
you